لا تطورات العمليه العسكريه التركيه في
شمال سوريا حيث افادت مصادر محليه للجزيره
بان الجيش التركي قصفت مركزات لما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه شمال الرقه
بمدفعيته المنتشره في مناطق المعارضه
شمالي وغربي سوريا كما سادف الجيش التركي
ايضا مواقع هذه القوات غرب مدينه تل ابيض
في الرقه وفي قريه تل اللبن بريفيتال تمر
شمال الحسكه وقالت ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه انها قتلت 18 من قوات
المعارضه السوريه المسلحه اثناء ردها على
استهداف الجيش التركي لمواقعها ومحاولته
التقدم الى مناطقطقها
من جهته قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان انه لا يمكن لبلاده ان تظل صامته
ازاء التهديدات الصادره ممن وصفهم
بالارهابيين في شمالي سوريا واكد اردوغان
قبل مغادرته لا تركمانستان للمشاركه في
قمه ثلاثيه تجمعه مع نظري تركمانستاني
والاذربيجاني انقره لا يمكنها التنازل عن
اهدافها في سوريا وفق تعبيره
عن توقيت للعمليه العسكريه التركيه في
شمال سوريا ولا العنوان الذي تستهدفه لقد
ذكرت السيده بوتن بالاهداف التي توصلنا
اليها في قمه سوشي واهممها انشاء منطقه
امنه خاليه من الارهابيين بعمق 30 كلم على
طول حدودنا لان دولهنا للاسف تحت التهديد
المستمر للارهابيين الذين ينطلقون من هذه
المناطق علما ان التهديدات زادت في الفتره
الاخيره بشكل جدي لا يمكن لنا ان نتنازل
عن اهدافنا في سوريا فنحن الدوله التي
تعاني من الارهاب من الممكن ان نتخذ في
شمال سوريا نفس الخطوات التي سبق ان
اتخذناها في منطقه عمليات المخلب القفل في
شمال العراق
على ارضنا